I think architects are more necessary
than ever because technology can
sometimes create the illusion that a
building can be created without a
creative hand,
without a creative idea behind it.
And that's not true at all.
Where technology has helped so far is in
the building of extraordinary shapes
that architects can imagine.
So,
uh,
you know,
was once possible to imagine strange and
complicated shapes that were almost
impossible to build today.
Technology allows us to build almost
anything but the computer can't create
those things.
It can't make them up.
I'm an architect has to make them up.
Um,
and in fact,
if we think about frank gary again,
um,
he is in many ways a very traditional
architect.
I mean,
he designs on paper and with models and
then the computer takes over.
Only later.
Now there's a younger generation of
architects who were using the computer
more as a design tool up and they're
comfortable with letting the computer
tells them what to do a little bit more,
uh,
rather than merely how to make something
that their mind has invented a,
I don't know where that's going to take
us.
Um,
I'm,
I don't,
I don't think of myself as all,
but I think I'm old enough to not sort
of naturally feel that that's the way to
do it,
but I'm also,
I hope smart enough not to rush to
judgment on it.
So let's see,
um,
were using the computer as an actual
design tool as opposed to an engineering
and construction tool or as a
facilitation tool where all that takes
us.
Um,
I don't know yet,
but I do believe that in the same way
that computers can be programmed to
write music,
to paint pictures to a write literature.
Um,
I don't know that there will be a time
when they will equal the creative genius
of a human mind,
but they suddenly can facilitate that
genius and that we're seeing already
think we can get sort of tired of crazy
shapes all the time and we get numb to
them.
Uh,
you know,
and if every,
as Robert Venturi and Denise Scott Brown
wrote many,
many years ago,
you know,
if every building is extraordinary,
well then they're really ordinary.
Uh,
so that if the new ordinary just becomes
this kind of frantic,
frenetic,
complicated form a,
I don't know that we've achieved much
the,
uh,
the beauty and the drama in any kind of
urban environment,
any kind of urban setting is in the way
in which different things play against
each other.
I mean,
if you had a building like Frank Gary's
Walt Disney Hall in Los Angeles,
uh,
next door to another gehry building next
door to another,
uh,
all of the same thing.
I don't,
or equally a powerful buildings by other
architects.
I don't know that you'd have a
particularly appealing urban
environment,
but in the same way that,
you know,
a great cathedral in a European city
plays off against the everyday buildings
that are there and becomes a kind of
punctuation mark,
if you will.
And the city scape,
that's what we should be doing.
Is Technology going to create a
temptation to do too much all the time?
Uh,
it may,
but,
uh,
as I said,
I think our,
our growing awareness of urbanism,
of the idea of the city,
which I think is better understood
culturally today than it was 20 years
ago.
Uh,
I think that,
that,
that sort of helps balance that off.
And,
uh,
we're much more aware that the
background building in fact can be,
uh,
one of the things that makes a city
really nice to be it.
We think about Paris,
you know,
they're,
they're great monuments,
but then there's the kind of the
ordinary everyday Parisian building that
creates the urban fabric.
And that's one of the reasons it works
so well is because the great monuments
play off in,
in,
in a really beautiful,
sort of harmonic balance against the,
uh,
the background fabric.